[Musique]
on pense qu'on est capable avec la
situation actuelle des finances
publiques à la fois de donner un répit
du côté des impôts donc de remettre de
l'argent dans le portefeuille des
Québécois incluant la classe moyenne et
continue de mieux financer les services
entre autres en éducation en santé
[Musique]
premier budget du second mandat du
gouvernement de François Legault a moins
d'un virage à 180 degrés le ministre des
Finances Éric Girard devrait annoncer
les baisses d'impôts promise en campagne
pour réduire le fardeau fiscal des
contribuables québécois qui sont parmi
les plus lourdement taxés au pays
mesurent risquées selon certains surtout
si l'économie de Vincent bourbé
davantage la directrice de l'Institut du
Québec est l'une des sceptiques j'ai
rencontré Emna Braham OHC à Montréal
bonjour merci d'être avec nous bonjour
budget du Québec qui va être déposé
mardi commençons qu'est-ce que vous
allez surveiller qu'est-ce que vous
voulez voir dans ce document de Monsieur
Gérard alors ça va être probablement le
premier budget plus difficile pour le
ministre on sait que les revenus ont été
au rendez-vous au cours des dernières
années malgré la pandémie avec les
mesures d'aide avec l'inflation les
revenus ont été au rendez-vous là on
s'en va vers un budget peut-être un peu
plus difficile où les revenus pour les
prochaines années vont être un petit peu
moins
plus limité aussi la croissance un
potentiel de croissance qui est plus
limité à court terme on sait on s'en va
vers un ralentissement économique modéré
mais quand même un ralentissement
économique au cours de la prochaine
année mais aussi il faut pas oublier que
le potentiel de croissance économique à
plus long terme va être plus faible que
ce qu'on a vu au cours des années très
pandémiques monsieur Gérard a tout de
même dit à plusieurs reprises
à cette émission et encore quelques
semaines que les réductions d'impôts les
baisses d'impôts qui avaient été
promises par son parti durant la
campagne électorale c'était toujours
dans les cartons malgré l'incertitude
économique c'est une bonne idée alors ça
peut se comprendre
décidé de baisser les impôts pour les
particuliers c'est une décision un choix
de société la promesse a été faite à ces
clairement en campagne électorale
la coalition Amir Québec a été élue
majoritaire et donc on peut dire qu'il y
a une certaine adhésion à ce choix de
société par contre on peut regretter que
ça ait pas été fait dans un contexte de
débat sur les finances publiques et sur
la fiscalité plus large parce que c'est
une décision qui va avoir un impact sur
nos finances publiques de quelle façon
qu'est-ce que vous les avez pas plus
large qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu
voir
d'abord est-ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que lorsqu'on lorsqu'on se défait d'une
certaine source de revenus comme
lorsqu'on diminue les impôts sur les
particuliers donc on se on laisse aller
une certaine part des revenus attendus
mais ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on va venir
jouer probablement sur trois choses sur
la qualité des services sur le sol
budgétaire ou sur notre niveau
d'endettement là la proposition qui a
été faite c'est de pas toucher aux deux
premiers mais plutôt de toucher sur
notre de toucher à notre niveau
d'endettement en finançant cette baisse
d'impôts en allant piger dans les
versements prévus au fond des
générations donc les décisions
politiques vous l'avez dit il avait
promis
la carte l'avait promis on tient la
promesse est-ce qu'on aurait dû revoir
et dire dans le contexte sous le
gouvernement veut aider les familles qui
ont peut-être un peu plus difficultés à
traverser la période économique actuelle
est-ce que une aide plus ponctuelle
n'aurait pas été plus prudent
aussi un des enjeux c'est que on vient
quand même faire une proposition qui est
permanente ça va être très difficile de
réaugmenter les impôts par la suite donc
c'est une solution permanente pour un
enjeu qui semble quand même temporaire
donc on sait on a un contexte économique
qui est bien particulier on a à la fois
l'inflation qui est encore très élevé on
a les taux d'intérêt qui augmentent donc
les taux se resserre sur les ménages il
sentent cette pression ce stress
financier
certains ont besoin d'aide
donc on veut aider par contre on vient
quand même
se défaire d'une source de revenus à
très long terme donc est-ce que c'est la
meilleure solution
d'un point de vue de d'arbitrage entre
les objectifs à court terme et à long
terme c'est une question qui se pose
puis d'un autre côté est-ce qu'on veut
mieux cibler cette aide certainement
pour des raisons d'équité on voudrait
cibler plutôt les ménages à plus faibles
revenus donc ça aurait peut-être été
avantageux d'être un peu plus pointu
dans l'approche quand vient le temps
d'aider les familles les contribuables
québécois c'est ce que vous dites
exactement je pense que la démonstration
économique
de cette baisse d'impôts elle reste à
faire parce que on en a parlé d'une part
pour contrer le hausse du coût de la vie
par contre on sait que ça va venir un
petit peu plus tard en 2023 là où
l'inflation va être encore élevé mais
quand même en ralentissement est-ce que
ça pourra aussi avoir un effet sur de
stimulation de la croissance économique
c'est pas certain dans un contexte de
plein emploi
on a parlé de prévisions évidemment on
parle d'un léger ralentissement
peut-être dans le négatif un peu plus
tard cette année si jamais ça devait
s'avérer pire que ce que l'on envisage
que ce que les prévisionnistes
envisagent à l'heure actuelle l'impact
que ça va avoir sur quel impact est-ce
que cela aurait sur le budget que
Monsieur Girard s'apprête à déposer
c'est une bonne question parce que le
ralentissement économique qu'on prévoit
il est relativement modéré mais un
niveau d'incertitude puis de risque qui
reste important est-ce que la politique
monétaire va vraiment réussir à calmer
l'inflation en tant qu'on l'espère
est-ce que les risques géopolitiques
qu'on voit en Europe en Asie vont se
matérialiser donc le niveau de risque il
est important on est d'accord là-dessus
quel effet ça peut avoir sur les
finances publiques d'une part c'est
qu'on peut se dire que est-ce qu'on va
devoir mettre des mesures plus
spécifiques pour aider les entreprises
pour aider les ménages si le
ralentissement est plus sévère qu'on
l'imagine
là on vient de se défaire d'une certaine
marge de manœuvre pour faire face à ces
enjeux-là le gouvernement risque de
tracer la voie vers l'équilibre
budgétaire il semble avoir beaucoup de
pression pour tenter de ramener tout ça
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
prudent de le faire compte tenu de la
situation économique très instable et un
peu difficile dans laquelle on se trouve
présent
l'équilibre budgétaire c'est un petit
peu la condition première pour atteindre
nos autres objectifs financiers donc on
veut retourner à l'équilibre budgétaire
on a suspendu la loi en 2021 pour se
donner un petit peu plus de marge de
manœuvre pour ne pas devoir couper dans
les dépenses de manière abrupte et alors
qu'on était en pleine pandémie et qu'on
savait que les enjeux économiques
étaient là pour perdurer la question
c'est plutôt de dire
est-ce qu'on veut modifier cette loi
moderniser quelque part exactement parce
qu'on le voit pendant les deux
principales crises économiques qu'on a
connu on a dû suspendre cette loi donc
ça ça reste tributaire d'une décision
politique de suspendre puis de reprendre
la loi alors qu'on pourrait peut-être
moderniser cette loi pour la rendre un
petit peu plus flexible c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'on peut se dire on revient à
l'équilibre budgétaire lorsque le
potentiel de l'économie revient à la
normale est-ce qu'on peut se donner une
durée un petit peu plus longue pour
revenir à l'équilibre budgétaire c'est
des questions qui se posent cette loi
elle est quand même elle a près d'un
quart de siècle maintenant est-ce qu'on
veut la moderniser c'est une question
que que le misérable va se poser oui
mardi qu'est-ce que les Québécois en
général monsieur madame tout le monde
devrait surveiller plus attentivement
dans le budget de Monsieur Gérard ça va
être un budget de transition on rend
vraiment dans le monde d'après la
pandémie alors on va vouloir voir un
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire dans un
délai raisonnable on va vouloir voir une
nouvelle cible d'endettement c'est des
éléments qui peuvent paraître peut-être
un petit peu obscur mais c'est ce qui
nous assure une équité
intergénérationnelle c'est ce qui nous
assure de ne pas refiler la facture à
nos enfants merci infiniment d'avoir été
des nôtres merci pour l'invitation